here's a trick that I want you to try to
break the pattern of being paralyzed
that will be your life forever until you
break it look it doesn't matter what the
other people think
other than my customers other than my
you know my partners other than my
employee
rise and shine it's expresso time what's
up believe nation its Evan this channel
is designed to be a part of your daily
success routine and help you believe in
your Michael Jordan level talent so
let's start your day off right together
grab your coffee and sip on today's
message stop caring what others think
over to you Mel Robbins so we've been
getting a ton of questions about being
paralyzed with the fear of what other
people think and this is so commonplace
I think every human being on the planet
is is paralyzed in some aspect or some
area of their life because they're
concerned about what their parents or
but the friends are with the friends on
Facebook or with their colleagues or
with their upline or their downline or
whatever what their neighbors are gonna
think if you are struggling with this
and you have not found it helpful to
attack your thinking patterns then
here's a trick that I want you to try to
break the pattern of being paralyzed by
what other people think I want you to
pick one thing one thing that you've
been wanting to do that you've been
thinking about but you have stopped
yourself from doing because you're
concerned about what other people think
let me give you some examples maybe
you've wanted to go on a wellness
retreat but you think your spouse will
roll their eyes at you so you haven't
done it maybe you have a particular
Facebook post or blog so many of you
want to start a business or start
creating art but you're terrified of
putting yourself out there because of
what other people will think today we're
gonna break that pattern what you're
going to do is you're gonna pick one
thing you've been stopping yourself from
doing and you're going to do it you're
going to do it and the reason why I want
you to do this is because I know that if
you're still paralyzed you have not been
able to change
thinking patterns yet that's cool no
problem we're gonna try a different
tactic I want you to change this
paralysis through action because if you
sign up for that class if you go on that
retreat if you create your art if you
post that blog post if you start that
business you will be proving to yourself
through the actions that you're taking
that you don't care what other people
think try that today let me know number
one what you've stopped yourself from
doing and number two what you're
committing to doing today because one
way to break this is to attack the
thoughts and change the thoughts and get
into action first the other way to do it
is to recognize that you're paralyzed
pick one thing that you're gonna do and
actually get it done people aren't
afraid of feeling they're afraid of
feeling in front of somebody else the
solution is you need to inoculate
yourself against judgment people are so
afraid to rock the boat but in your
inability to rock the boat you end up
not living the life that you want you
need to stop that so Mel's idea is great
take the thing that you want to do that
you're afraid of failing that you're
afraid of being judged for and just go
out and do something take action for me
it's not even so much the things that I
want to do anytime that I feel myself
playing small because of somebody else's
potential opinion then I have to go off
and do that thing it's building the
muscle every time that you are afraid of
somebody else's opinion of you and then
you don't do that thing you are training
yourself to play small you are training
yourself to say they're worried about
what I'm gonna do and so I am NOT going
to do that and it repeats that pattern
consistently that will be your life
forever until you break it where any
time you find yourself worried about
somebody else's opinion that's the
reason why you're not gonna do something
then for me I have to go off and do that
thing even if I didn't want to do that
thing because building the muscle of
inoculating myself against judgment is
more important than doing the thing that
I love doing or not so the example I
share is around getting my nails done
I took my dance team after they won a
local competition out to
salon and we were celebrating with
getting our nails done and the women
joked if I was gonna get my nails done
or not and my initial reaction was not
liking my nails done but there was a
piece of me that I didn't want to do it
because I was worried about how people
would judge me I was worried that I had
to go and do big meetings I had to do a
presentation I had to do YouTube videos
I had to go on Instagram live I had a
bunch of stuff to do that would be very
public and I didn't want people to see
me with my painted nails on and because
that was a piece of the reason it wasn't
the entire reason but because that was a
piece of the reason then I had to go and
get my nails painted just to inoculate
myself against that judgment the only
acceptable answer is that this is not an
expression of myself if you are faced
with a task or if somebody is judging
you for something and the result for you
is this is not an expression of myself
and you fully believe that that is 100%
of the reason then you're good but if
part of the reason why you are afraid to
jump into something whether it's pursue
your business and do the thing you want
to do or something that you don't
actually care that much about like
getting your nails done then in my view
you have to go off and do that thing
because if you are afraid of getting
your nails painted how are you gonna go
off and be an entrepreneur and pursue
this crazy mission you want to be
playing up here you want to accomplish
these big things and that's gonna come
with a lot of judgment a lot of haters a
lot of negativity how are you gonna do
that when you are afraid to get your
nails painted and so I think too many
entrepreneurs are trying to go to the
gym lift a thousand pounds where the key
he think it started is just start
building a little bit of strength go in
and lift two pounds and five pounds in
ten pounds and 15 pounds and 25 pounds
and every time you're in there lifting
weights and getting stronger you're able
to do the next thing and the next thing
and the next thing and so the key
message is to inoculate yourself against
judgment any time you catch yourself
playing small because you're worried
about somebody else's opinion then you
have to go and do that thing now I've
got a really special bonus clip that I
think you're gonna enjoy but before that
question of the day I want to know what
is one thing that you are gonna work on
today
is one action you're gonna take today to
help you inoculate yourself against
other people's judgement leave it down
in the comments below
most people really are concerned about
what people think about them it holds
them back you never ever ever ever have
it's not a part of who you are is that
your DNA or where did that come from I
don't know I just never gave me yeah
it's just once you get success in
something I mean even when look I failed
many times and you learn from those
failures that it doesn't hurt as bad as
you thought you know that you can bounce
back and then once you taste some
success you realize it doesn't matter
how many times you failed right you only
have to be one right one time then
everyone's always an overnight success
or you know this came easy to them you
know you just you just got to keep on
grinding and and keep on trying new
things and you know once you start
feeling the success you realize look it
doesn't matter what the other people
think
other than my customers other than my
you know my partners other than my
employees I care what they think but you
know from the outside looking in I was
always just so focused that I just never
I mean I got distracted from time I
don't want to say never distracted but
you know I just didn't want anybody else
I don't want to think that how people
saw me was a reflection of the job I was
doing you know if my customers were
happy
if stakeholders were happy I was happy
the first woman driver to lead a lap
under Bree in a NASCAR Sprint Cup Series
how do you handle it when someone talks
bad about you for the whole world to
hear Shh I say whatever I'm confident I
know that no you don't ever like when
somebody says something negative about
you but I believe in myself
you have to just remember all the things
that it took to get there and
that they weren't easy and then it
allows me to say things like I really
don't care what people say about me on a
bigger macro patience and failure they
all ladder up to one thing which is
insecurity the reason people don't put
themselves in a position to fail the
reason people aren't patient is they
value other people's opinions too much
which then dictates their behavior which
then gets into all of this Wise's if you
like don't hold on to it and with the
thought of in case it fails because you
just need to realize it's your Scarlet
Letter literally the reason people are
scared always is the outside force
having a failing business and everyone's
like Oh see you could never do or
whatever the cliche right yeah it's just
matter you know why so that's one piece
and even if it didn't succeed
what there's such better people like
what I'm such a better person than other
people because I can build a business
that's a bull raise your standard Apple
at the cool its core value is that
passion not one drop of myself work
depends on your it's something serene if
you want to learn more formal I highly
recommend checking out the top fifty
rules of success fitter than I made the
link is right next to me continue to
believe I hope you enjoyed today's shot
a vinspresso and I'll see you on the
next video I'm about to change your life
because this piece of research changed
by